Now it often happens that when doing something like an exam on
Tomasulo's Algorithm. We just care, for
example, like in what cycle something issues or
in what cycle something finishes, and so on, or how many cycles it took overall.
So let's go to an example that is just trying to track the timing and
not trying to keep track of everything in every structure, and
so on, just to kind of show you how to do this on exams. So we will have
the same processor, the same instructions, the same issue, execute write.
But we're going to try to do that without having all of those tables in. So
let's try to go through this example. Whats going to happen is we kind of need
to know how many reservation stations we have for each type of instructions. And
that's the only thing that we're kind of going to be missing a little bit.
So, basically, in the first cycle we know we can issue this and
nothing else will happen. In the next cycle, we know we can execute this and
then because it takes three cycles. We know that we're going to try to write it
in cycle 4. So kind of mark this tentatively now for cycle 4. In the next cycle,
we will be issuing this load here. If we consider the same condition that
the load cannot overlap with another load, then we know that in 2 and 3,
this is going to execute, so that this can begin execution in 4, and
then execute in 5, and try to broadcast in 6. In cycle 3,
we're going to be issuing this. It uses a different unit. So, again,
you have to check basically. In cycle 3, is there an available multiply unit but
kind of looking at what is currently using the reservation stations? And then,
you have to check for dependencies. So, for example, this is waiting for F2 and
F4. F2 is produced by the second load, so actually this will not be able to
execute until cycle 7. 6 here means that basically we will have 7.
And we can kind of mark here that our F2 comes from instruction 2,
which is why he had to execute only in the cycle that follows its write.
Because this is a multiplication, add 10 cycles to that. We're going to try to
write the result in cycle 17. The subtract is going to issue in
the very next cycle if there are available reservation stations because, so
far, we have used no add reservation stations that's going to be able to issue.
The subtract is going to wait for 2 and 6, so
the later of the two loads is really when we can start. So we can
start in cycle 7. And we will mark here again that, you know, we are waiting.
Kind of just give an indication like what was the delay somewhere. And then,
it's a subtract, so it's going to finish in cycle 8, 7, 8. So it's going to
try to write the result in 9. Next, we're going to consider this divide.
Can it issue in in cycle 5? Well, yes it can because, so far, only
one unit is used, then we have two such, only one reservation station is using.
We have two of them. So the question is when can it execute? Well, look for
F0 and F6. F0 comes from the multiply, it's 17. F6 comes at 4,
so we will be able to execute in cycle 18 here because we were waiting for
F0 like this. And it's a divide, so it's going to try to broadcast at cycle 58.
Next, we're going to consider, what's the next issue cycle. Well,
6. This add is going to issue in 6 because, again, we have units.
It's going to look for F8 and F2, whichever is the latest. 2 is at 6,
F8 is at 9, so it's going to start executing in cycle 10,
execute in cycle 11, try to broadcast in cycle 12. And
we're going to mark that F8 comes from instruction 4.
And now, because we've been kind of doing this out of order, we have to check
just are there any two instructions that are actually writing in the same cycle.
If yes then we'll have to redo this. Basically, we have to postpone some of
the writes in order for that to happen. But because these are all different
cycles, everything is fine And this concludes our timing example. So, basically,
now we know in which cycle each instruction executes issues and writes. And
when does this all end without really having to go through all of those things?
So if we're only worried about timing, then we can do something like this.